Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Like, no other FUWAMOCO Morning.
It's something new, right?
Thank you for joining us for our 7th episode!
7 already!
To explain, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, Monday.
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please make sure to tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, good morning!
Good morning, BAU BAU!
Well, to start the day off, we have another... There's been another... Pero Sighting!
Everyone was holding their breath there.
So long!
Where did we find Pero this time?
Ruffians, where did you find him?
De-den!
Pero, what are you doing?
Wait, wait.
He's the more of an Asian in the Philippines.
He's Pero-ing it.
Pero!
You have to stop that, okay?
It's a mall, so you should be.
Is that what you're saying?
In Pero's defense though, you know, it does look kind of interesting to look, right?
Like a big candy.
Like, what would it taste like, you know?
Maybe like a bit zappy, like Pop Rocks?
Zappy zappy.
Like Biboo, eh?
Biboo?
Ah, Kami-senpai!
Good morning!
Maybe like Biboo?
Oh, it tastes like Biboo.
I was thinking the zappy part.
Oh, maybe Biboo could be a zappy taste too?
Pop Rocks, Pop Rocks.
No.
Right.
Yeah.
But hopefully he doesn't drive away any customers, right?
They need their business, too.
It's a mall after all, right?
But, I don't know.
It would be helpful if maybe the mall security could shoo him back to our way, you know?
Send him back over here, you know?
Well, Ruffians, if you see Pero again, please let us know.
You don't have to let you know.
You already know if you see him.
Let us know if you have any more sightings if you use the hashtag FWMCMORNING.
I hope we can get Pero back soon.
Will he come back home soon?
Do we need him?
Not really, but it just doesn't feel right, you know?
Doesn't feel right.
We're out in good news!
Good news!
Did you notice, Ruffians?
Ruffians!
You know what happened last time?
De-den!
Awesome!
We can't believe it!
We've reached 1 million views on our debut stream!
BAU BAU!
We're so happy.
It's also really crazy too, right?
Crazy.
There are over 1 million Ruffians out there now, right?
What if some Ruffians watched it like a thousand times each?
That was a Ruffian.
In their heart.
And they're a Ruffian in my heart.
I see, I see.
Like to us, if you know FUWAMOCO, you're a Ruffian.
To us.
Maybe you don't feel that way, but I'm sorry, that's how we feel.
If you feel like, nah, I'm not a Ruffian, I don't want to be a Ruffian, that's okay.
That's okay too.
We'll just be waiting here forever and ever for you.
Watch out.
We're gonna protect your smile.
You won't even know, okay?
You won't know it.
But you know, now that it's been a little while since our debut, we've gotten to know each other a bit more.
Ruffians, what were your favorite moments from our debut?
We were nervous.
Did you like it?
I guess if a million people liked it, maybe they'd like it.
Or watched it, maybe they'd watch it.
I was like, oh!
That's a positive way of thinking!
Lifetime Showtime!
Your favorite part was the BAU BAU part.
Do not the tail.
Don't touch the fuzz.
You remember, do not the ears either, right?
Both parts are important, you know?
The first part.
What about the middle part?
What about the last part?
Thank you, Ruffians!
Well now, I guess it's just gonna be a good memory that we share all together, right?
The start of our journey together.
Thank you, Ruffians!
Ruffians, you remember what happened last FUWAMOCO Morning, right?
Right.
We had something good happen, right?
We did!
There was some really good news.
I guess, you know, Rebellion hit 1 million views.
There's a lot of good news.
You know, which is even more good news is our debut.
But... But... De-den.
There's been another misunderstanding.
We thought that maybe, you know, we'd be able to reach today and not have another misunderstanding that we'd be safe.
We're not perfect.
Not at all.
There's been another misunderstanding.
Just a few hours ago earlier in a Japanese chatting stream.
A fresh misunderstanding.
And it wasn't my fault.
Mococo is good.
I'm clear.
I said something I shouldn't have.
I made a mistake.
That's surprising, huh?
Saying something you shouldn't have?
I messed up my words a little, and I might have accidentally created a new food.
A new food called Hayashi Chuka.
See, there's two foods.
There's Hiyashi Chuka, which is like a cold noodle that's on the left there.
And there's Hayashi Rice, which is like... Hayashi sauce is like a...
Like a hashed beef.
Yeah, sort of thing.
Yeah.
No.
And now, you know what?
You know what?
Now there's a lot of Ruffians making the Hayashi Chuka!
Yeah!
So fast!
Already making Hayashi Chuka.
Please don't get tummy aches, okay?
Yeah, no tummy aches.
It's not our fault, okay?
If you get a tummy ache.
You know, Hayashi Chuka is yummy.
Hayashi Chuka is really yummy.
And Hayashi Rice is really yummy.
But together...
BAU BAU!
I think maybe the Ruffians are just being nice.
Maybe a bit nice.
The Ruffians are very nice.
Don't mix it!
No mixing.
I don't think that'll be very pleasant.
Please make sure you enjoy your Hiyashi Chuka as Hiyashi Chuka and your Hayashi Rice as Hayashi Rice.
Okay!
Wow.
Savvy.
There has been another misunderstanding.
But you know, this time, this time, Ruffians, it's not our fault.
It's not!
It's not our fault!
No, this time, we actually have a very special video appearance from a certain Advent member.
Yeah, what's the problem?
Okay, let's take a look here then.
Okay.
BAU BAU!
Jailbirds, Adventrix, and hololive fans alike, I have a misunderstanding that I need to clear up.
Sadly, this misunderstanding was caused by no one except myself.
You see, during my debut stream, I was so nervous, as you could probably tell, and when I was describing my Japanese language skills, I accidentally said that I could read 2,000 kanji.
What I meant to say is, I know 2,000 Japanese words.
I only know about maybe a thousand kanji, and even then it's not every single reading of them.
It's just a few, and it's if they're in words that I know.
So I know the general meaning, but that's it.
I'm really sorry for this horrible misunderstanding, and I hope you guys can forgive me.
No reisai!
Ruffians, what do you think?
She should feel bad!
Unforgivable very very bad!
What do you think?
No!
What?
It's an easy mistake!
Unforgivable.
Wait, how could she?
How could she?
Why?
Yeah.
It's an easy... Dogeza.
I want to see the versus Dogeza.
You know, it's an easy mistake.
When she said that during debut, we were both really surprised.
We were like, what?
She's super strong in Japanese.
What's she hiding?
Why is she hiding from us sort of thing?
It makes sense now, you know?
But, you know, understanding 2,000 words and knowing a thousand kanji, that's really amazing!
It's really amazing.
Right!
You know, she should be very, very, very proud of that accomplishment.
And you know, you can sort of understand.
You know, debut is a very nerve-wracking time.
You can sort of be like... And all the words come out.
I'm a...
Demon... Dark God.
Dark God!
That never happened, we never said that.
Ruffians, what about you?
Do you know 2,000 words and 1,000 kanji?
How is your Japanese language journey going?
I'm curious, honestly!
It doesn't have to be a big journey.
Right, right.
2,000 words is amazing, right?
Right!
M4 level, right?
Two!
See?
That's two more than zero, though.
Yeah.
So you should honestly be, like, proud of that.
Right, you know.
Even if you're still just at the beginning.
It's something good, okay?
Yeah.
Right?
Now we all understand, right?
Right, Ruffians?
Jailbirds?
Frenchicks?
Yeah.
Nurses Forgiven?
Forgiven?
Yeah.
She doesn't need to go back into the cell?
Go back?
She's good?
Yes?
She's forgiven?
No!
Yes?
Yes.
I think so, but I would still kind of like to be able to see it together.
Why?
3D debut, that's the first thing.
Ah, okay.
That sounds good.
That sounds like it makes sense.
Ruffian Sabers, don't you want to see that?
Nerissa on the ground.
Dogeza-ing.
I'm sorry.
I think that would be a good... What does that mean?
It's forgiven.
We love you Nobisa, don't worry.
I still want to see the look of Doggy-san.
Today we have a new segment.
A new corner.
Maybe it's gonna be a bit of a rarer one.
De-den!
Today's Dream!
Yes, yes.
Today's new corner.
In case you didn't know, both of us, we can be pretty avid dreamers.
Both when we're awake and when we're sleeping.
Yeah, in case you couldn't tell by the big golden dreams list, you know.
Yeah, you know, and sometimes...
They can both be very intense.
But today, we're gonna take a look at Mococo's dream.
Moco-chan, what was your dream like?
Can you let us know the details?
So listen closely, okay?
I'm only gonna say it once.
I'm all ears.
I was in... Now, now, this is, this is a real, real deal.
It's real, it's not made up.
I'm not... That's why this is a rare corner, because it's real.
So I was in a classroom filled with a bunch of Ruffians.
Okay?
Then my tummy, it started to grumble.
And it let out a really big...
Wow.
Then suddenly, everyone around me started crying because of the song.
And then I told them that it's okay, don't worry, cheer up!
It was just that nostalgic.
It brought back the feels.
That was my dream.
Must have been a really big one.
What do you think, Ruffians?
You're one of the Ruffians in a dream?
I'm sure.
What is your instrument?
What do you mean?
It was my tummy.
Your tummy?
Shiny, smiley tummy.
Well, that was Moco-chan's dream.
Usually, Fuwawa dreams more.
My dreams can be something.
They're very long.
I'd like you to know all the details, how I felt.
What the temperature was like, those kind of things, you know?
It's necessary.
I don't think it's that necessary.
Moco-chan's went to the point.
To the point, yeah.
Everyone cried.
That's one of the differences with us as twins.
We explain our dreams differently.
Good to know!
Next!
We talked about this next part in our
We didn't have much time to really talk about it, so we thought that it was important to talk maybe a bit more about it.
What we'd like to talk about today is we love cats!
Cats!
That's a steak, you know?
Right there.
Yeah, and now I know there's a lot of cat lovers at hololive.
Yeah, right.
But, I'm kind of tempted to say that we're the biggest cat lovers.
I would say that we're the biggest cat lovers.
You know, like we said in my debut, you know, kittens are good for eating, and cats are for huffing.
Hugging is good too, but particularly huffing is really, really good.
Yeah, like the big gunka gunka.
And we like cats more than kittens because, you know,
Kittens are good, but the great part of cats is their personality.
Some of them are sort of like spicy, and some of them are sort of friendly, and some are clingy, and some are just loud.
Loud cats are cute!
You know, kittens haven't really developed those personalities yet, so that's why.
They're just like, oh, I'm cute!
Look, I'm gonna fall over!
Look at my tail!
Oh, I don't know how to do it!
You know?
You just see them and you just want to eat them, right?
You know cats?
They're fully matured!
They have personality!
They're cute, too!
You know, but you can get to know them.
Yeah, you can sort of figure out what makes them happy, what makes them sort of angry.
You know, like, even with the ears.
You know, and all types of cats are good, you know.
But I guess our favorite's like a really dense, fluffy, fuzzy cat.
You know, soft fur, but it's got a good amount of fudge to it.
You know, like, round face.
Round face.
Grab the cheeks.
Yeah, so the squatters with round ears are really good, too.
But normal cute ears are good, too.
Those are really strong.
But it's nice to, like, put your finger near the ear and make them sort of go, waaah.
I don't like this.
You're cute though.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna tease you.
I'm gonna go away.
I'm gonna follow you.
Every part of the cat is so good.
The chest, the tummy, the cheeks.
We talked about the mouth, the ears, the ears.
Don't forget the ears.
You know, the back.
The back is good.
The thighs!
The tails, the paws.
You know, the fur in between the fingers.
That's a good chew.
The tail, did I say the tail?
The tail, yeah.
It's all good.
You know, if the tail's kind of hanging off something, you can go and be like, oh, you're a fish, I'm gonna bite it!
Ow!
Ow.
Yeah, it's all good.
Yeah.
In case you didn't know, we don't have a cat.
No, we don't.
We don't have a cat.
But we do have a limit on how much cat media we can consume in a day.
Yeah.
Yeah, we really like cats.
We really, really love cats.
We really love cats.
You get it now!
We really, really like cats.
Please, you know, if you see a cat, if you have a cat, please go play and hug it and kiss it and huff it for us.
The kissing has to be very intense, okay?
Intense, intense.
We just wanted to explain that so you understand.
We really like cats.
Got it?
Thank you, thank you.
Yes, we really like cats.
Delicious.
Delicious cats.
But we talked about cats now.
Let's go on to our next segment, Doggie of the Day!
A bit of whiplash here.
De-den!
Our doggy of today is Pudding!
And Pudding loves Greek yogurt.
Not pudding, you know it.
Right?
But Pudding loves it so much.
So much!
She gets a bit passionate and pretty expressive about it too.
Cute.
The yogurt on those.
But Moco-chan, you kind of get like this when you're eating something that's extra special you feel passionate about.
You know, like a parfait.
Maybe sometimes, but I think you do too.
I found some food on your face earlier.
But you know, I feel like, well, maybe us, maybe you more in particular, have something in common with pudding, you know?
Even the look in the eyes of pudding, right?
Greek Yogurt!
How does pudding BAU BAU?
Especially like, when eating the Greek Yogurt?
Isn't that a bit difficult?
The only thing in Pudding's heart is Greek Yogurt at that moment.
At that moment!
That's the important part.
It's just Greek Yogurt at that moment.
But after the Greek Yogurt...
It's love.
I was gonna say, I'd say that Pudding's really, you know, Pudding's the best friend that, you know, always has your best interests at heart.
Until, you know, you bring up the Greek yogurt, you don't wanna share.
Yeah, friendship over.
It ends there.
Thank you!
Enjoy the Greek Yogurt Pudding.
It's a good breakfast too, right?
Maybe Ruffians will choose Greek Yogurt for breakfast.
And pudding.
On to the next!
Today I went on a walk.
We have...
Did we go to the ocean?
An ocean sidewalk?
It's so pretty.
It looks so nice and comfortable.
It's probably like a nice breeze.
It kind of smells a bit salty.
A rock?
It's the ocean!
The ocean!
It must have been so relaxing to hear the sounds of the ocean.
This looks pretty rocky though.
I don't know, I feel like the water looks really yummy.
Yummy sea water.
Something you could drink.
It tastes like soda.
I guess you could drink it if you wanted to, Moco-chan, but... I don't take any responsibility.
Maybe.
But you know, do you see?
Ruffians!
There!
There's something on the rocks there!
There's a Sea Puffer!
Sea Puffer!
It's kind of maybe hard to tell them apart, but they're there.
They're really cute looking.
It's kind of chubby, too.
And I don't know if you can see here, but they're kind of making eye contact with the camera, too.
Eye contact.
Maybe they're a little bit curious, just like us.
You know, they're supposed to be tough, but I think I could definitely take one down in a fight.
Really?
They aren't that tough.
Yeah, so, you know, if one attacks you, I'll protect you.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Next we have our Question of the Day.
We answered a lot of questions earlier.
Here's another good question.
And then... Oh!
Hi, FUWAMOCO!
Hello!
My papa is super terrified of thunderstorms, so I was just curious, as Demon Guard Dogs, do you both like thunderstorms?
If not, how do you get through them?
BAU BAU for now.
BAU BAU!
I don't like loud sounds.
Yeah, I understand.
Yeah.
You know, we're scared of a lot of things too, even though we're doing our best.
I kind of mentioned it a bit in the Japanese Zatsudan stream earlier, but Moco-chan, it's kind of hard to do the laundry because the laundry machine makes a very loud sound.
So it's sort of like thunderstorms.
And you know, for us, thunderstorms are a bit scary at first, but as long as we're together, you know?
And once we realize that it's a thunderstorm, it's better.
It's okay, you know?
Thunderstorms are kinda cool too, you know.
Especially if there's lightning.
Yeah, I like looking at the lightning.
I just don't like the loud sounds.
Yeah, the loud sounds.
It's kinda scary.
If all of a sudden it's BAU BAU BAU.
Too surprising.
But yeah, we get it.
Loud things.
Sudden loud sounds.
Yeah.
Thank you Ruffians for the headpats!
Headpats with a paw for two, okay?
I think, you know, when we feel really scared, we just kinda go and curl up under some fluffy and fuzzy blankets too.
You know, we get like a warm heater.
Try to maybe relax the music, darken the room.
Keep it nice.
Yeah, try to get some rest.
Make it comfy.
You know, when you're not feeling good, it's good to take a rest.
Maybe that will help you poop for two!
Maybe.
Good blanket.
But, you know, there's a lot of things we're scared of, but I guess thunderstorms, it's not really one of them.
I think maybe, you know, we're scared of other things.
And maybe your puppy's not scared of other things, you're scared of thunderstorms.
But I think we can both get over it.
Together.
We believe that your puppy can conquer the fear too.
Let's do our best all together, okay?
Thank you!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
We're also always looking for more submissions for Pero Sightings, Doggie of the Day, to hear more about your vlogs and quiz questions, so please don't hesitate to submit yours with the hashtag right at the top up there.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Thank you!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Let's take a peek at what we have coming next.
Dan dan!
We're gonna be playing River City Girls later today.
It's our first time playing any of the Kunio-kun games series.
It's a brawler.
I'm playing.
Yeah, it's two players.
Moco-chan's playing.
I'm playing.
Yes.
Two player.
I shouldn't need to be backseating today.
You shouldn't need to, but... Do we think that Fuwawa's still gonna backseat today?
Do you?
Cuz... Do you?
I sort of feel like they're still gonna be backseating today.
Yes?
Yes, really.
I have my own controller.
Yes!
There's no no's, it's just...
Of course.
I'll prove you wrong.
Will you?
Ruffians, make sure you watch, okay?
Keep track if she backseats or not.
You have to watch, you know, make sure.
Ah, FUWAMOCO's actually better than Moco-chan.
She's getting more of the enemies.
They won't say that, no.
They'll say that.
But yes, please join us later today!
And for our schedule!
De-den!
We're at the middle of the week.
Almost at the middle of the week.
And tomorrow we're going back to Spooky Shopskill Mansion!
I'm not looking forward to it.
This time, we're gonna beat it!
We're gonna get to the thousandth room.
A thousandth?
A thousandth room!
No matter what.
Do you think you'll be okay, Ruffians?
Will we be able to do it?
It is getting a little bit scarier every time now, but... It was really scary last time too.
I can do it!
I believe.
No scary emotes.
No.
We'll do our best, the Ruffians will be there to help us, okay?
Yeah.
Okay.
We need your help for it, okay?
Yeah.
And then on Friday we have an Advent collab, but this time mine is Shiori, but we're playing Apex.
Apex.
And I play...
I'm holding the controller.
I'm holding the keyboard.
Holding the keyboard.
Whichever one.
You're gonna hold the keyboard.
I'm gonna hold the keyboard.
Okay.
That's an interesting way to play.
So you'll have to see just how amazing I am at Apex.
It'll be an exciting sight to see Avin Apex.
And then, on the weekend we're going to be playing two Nintendo games.
We're playing The Legend of Zelda Ocarina of Time for the first time.
And then back to Donkey Kong Country.
Donkey Kong Country.
Bananas, bananas, bananas, bananas.
Bananas, bananas.
We have a lot of fun things coming up, so Ruffians, we hope that you'll join us.
I feel a bit bad because I realized that maybe, you know, we've been doing a lot of streams.
Maybe it's been a bit tough for Ruffians to catch them all, you know?
We're sorry if we've been making you a bit like, oh, there's not enough time.
But we're really happy that you're here when you can be here with us too.
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
We'll always be waiting here.
We'll come back when you can.
BAU BAU!
Are we already at the time, Moco-chan?
It's that time already.
Well, you know, before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to do a shout out to some of our Extra Special Viewers today.
Panty!
BAU BAU!
Ransa!
Whale!
BAU BAU!
Siri!
Eagle!
BAU BAU!
Jayham!
And to every other Ruffian, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!